dans ce village de la région de Carson
libérée les stigmates de la guerre sont
partout visibles
c'était vraiment un beau village
certains villageois de retour chez eux
découvrent l'étendue de ce qu'ils ont
perdu comme Vassil fermier avant la
guerre
je ne sais pas ce qu'il faut faire ni
par où commencer vous le voyez bien tout
est détruit sans tracteur on ne peut
rien faire de ces terres je ne sais pas
quoi faire
selon cette rapatrié ukrainienne moins
de 200 personnes sont revenues dans le
village après sa libération
il faut tout recommencer à zéro c'est
pas grave nous allons tout faire pour
nous reconstruire nous sommes encore
jeune mais pour ceux qui n'ont rien à
sauver c'est différent il ne reviendront
pas
ici il faut vivre sans eau et sans
chauffage en pleine température
hivernale on cause des frappes de Moscou
contre les infrastructures énergétiques
du pays et le président russe ne compte
pas s'arrêter là
en ce moment il y a beaucoup de bruit
autour de nos attaques contre les
infrastructures énergétiques d'un pays
voisin oui nous le faisons mais qui a
commencé qui a frappé le pont de Crimée
ces dernières semaines des millions
d'ukrainien se sont retrouvés sont
courants sans eau et sans chauffage
selon l'opérateur au crin ergo le
système électrique était encore victime
ce jeudi d'un déficit significatif après
les dernières frappes russes lundi